(tense music)
- Greetings everyone.
Thanksgiving is coming,
less students are coming.
Today, we have a wonderful
opportunity to...
To close the historical part
of History of Ukraine course,
with guest lecturer, Professor Marci Shore.
She is Assistant Professor...
Associate Professor of history already
here at Yale.
Professor Marci Shore
teaches European cultural
and intellectual history.
She graduated with a bachelor's
and PhD from Stanford,
and holding master's degree
from University of Toronto.
She wrote it extensively on
intellectual history of
Eastern Central Europe.
And recently, she published book
on history of Euromaidan (indistinct)
was submitted to read,
"The Ukrainian Night: An
Intimate History of Revolution"
And today, we'll be particularly talking
about the years coming to Euromaidan,
and revolution itself,
and its consequences.
Marci, the floor is yours.
- Oh, thank you.
Thank you, it's nice to see you.
I'm recognizing some of you,
so I think some of you have listened
to me talk before, or taken my classes,
so hopefully this won't be too repetitive.
Let me start...
Let me start just briefly with...
With the fall of communism in 1989,
'cause this was also reminding me of
when I was younger.
One of the things Maidan
did was bring me back
to that moment when I
first became enchanted
with this whole part of the world,
with Eastern Europe.
And in 1989, when the Berlin Wall fell,
it was one of those things that felt
inconceivable and impossible
until the moment that it happened.
And then, in retrospect,
it seemed inevitable,
which I think is a lesson
for historians in general,
that the thing that seems
impossible and inconceivable
will seem that way
until the moment that it happens,
and then it will retrospectively seem
to be inevitable.
The Soviet Union seemed like
it would go on forever.
The one thing that struck me
when I first started
going to Eastern Europe
in the early 1990s was
how many people said to me,
"I never thought I would
see it end in my lifetime."
People who were dissidents,
people who sat in prison,
people who did everything
they could to protest,
people who did nothing,
people who were content,
people who went along with it;
Everybody said, "We never thought
"we would see it end in our lifetime."
And I know that you've all, by now,
sat through this whole course on Ukraine,
so you know a lot by now about
the Soviet experience.
So I'll just say, as a reminder,
in some sense to myself as well,
that the Soviet project was arguably
the largest, deepest,
most far reaching experiment
in social engineering
that has ever been performed on mankind.
And in some sense,
we are still grappling with
the sheer scope of the experiment,
and the sheer magnitude of the failure,
of the catastrophe.
It was not just an attempt
to remake a government,
and it wasn't even just an attempt
to remake a society.
It was an attempt to remake human beings.
It was an attempt to create
a new kind of human being.
And I was...
I was the last generation to grow up
during the Cold War.
The war was...
the world was divided into two camps.
There was an Iron Curtain,
not literal,
although in the case of the Berlin Wall,
there was actually physical wall.
The world was divided into those two sides
and you were never gonna see
what was on the other side.
Sorry, I'm trying to avoid
moving around too much,
which is my usual practice
because I see that there's a camera there,
so I'm gonna try to be disciplined
and stay right here.
And then, one day, it was over
and the wall fell, and the world opened.
And soon enough afterwards,
the Soviet Union seemed to dissolve.
Kind of, just dissolve into pieces.
Ukraine, as you probably heard,
got its independence,
to a certain extent, by default,
but also with some agitation,
and with some desire on the part
of the population.
And in the West, we were celebrating.
"The wicked witch is dead
"and now we all live happily ever after,"
that was the paradigm.
I always think of the Wizard of Oz,
and "Ding Dong, the witch is dead."
You've all seen the Wizard of Oz, yes?
"Ding dong, the witch is dead."
There was a sense that
the wicked witch is dead,
and now we were all gonna
live happily ever after.
Ironically, or perhaps paradoxically,
the Hegelian narrative that had been
underlying communism
all these years gave way
to what was also a Hegelian narrative
about a liberal teleology of progress,
that now that communism had failed
and now we knew that, in fact,
the locomotive of history was leading
towards liberal democracy.
And there was a sense that
liberalism, democracy,
free market neoliberalism,
they were all part of, what
Adam Michnik has called,
the "utopian capitalist package."
They were going together as part
of a harmonious whole,
and now, we were all going
to move on that train
and live happily ever after.
There had been wonderful
existentialist metaphysics
among dissidents and philosophers
in the 80s and 90s...
Or 70s and 80s, especially after 1968.
That kind of disappeared in the 90s
because everybody was
celebrating the end of history,
as Francis Fukuyama called it,
and the triumph of neoliberalism.
There was something
kind of smug about that.
Our smug Western triumphalism that,
yes, we were right,
now everybody lives happily ever after.
Now, in some sense,
that was a narrative that,
on both sides of the Iron Curtain,
was very deeply felt.
But something we perhaps
didn't appreciate so much,
being on the former capitalist side,
or the still capitalist side,
of the Iron Curtain was just
how brutal the 1990s were
for the societies that were
coming out of communism.
Nobody really knew how you go
and undo the communist experiment,
and try to get back on that locomotive.
Nobody really knew how you
made those transitions.
There were lots of theories.
There was shock therapy in Poland.
There was a faith that even if it were...
However rough it might be,
there were gonna be
some bumps in the road,
but now we knew where the road was going.
And the 1990s, I mean,
not only in the former Soviet space,
perhaps more dramatically in
the former Soviet space
than in the rest of Eastern Europe,
which was also quite rough.
One of my graduate students now,
who's from Albania, said,
there's an expression Albanian,
that's "it's not the 1990s,"
that references that you're
continually referencing
the trauma of the 1990s.
It took us a long time, I think,
in the West to understand that
the 1990s were traumatic.
There was a kind of wildness to it,
a sense that the old
rules no longer obtained
and nobody knew what the new rules were.
The coming of capitalism
came as a kind of what,
in American history we've called
"robber baron capitalism."
Capitalism as a wild free-for-all
with no rules.
It left open the possibility
of former communist apparatchiks
very quickly transitioning
into gangster-style neoliberals
who managed to monopolize
and steal a lot of the state resources.
The transition was not
particularly gentle,
and not necessarily
particularly fair at all.
So Ukraine was languishing
under these conditions,
as were other places.
It was called...
The Ukraine of the 1990s was called
by the American political
scientist, Keith Darden,
"The blackmail state,"
which was a term that got taken up.
Was mired in corruption scandals,
you probably heard a bit
from Professor Snyder
already about Leonid Kravchuk,
who came through the Communist Party.
And then, his successor, Leonid Kuchma,
who was entering politics around 1990,
and just mired in corruption scandals.
This omnipresence of corruption,
of this lawlessness that is accompanying
the transition to capitalism.
I mean, I still remember the transition
to capitalism even in so-called
"gentle places," like Prague,
where you just got in a cab
and they could charge
you any amount of money.
There was no in there being
any kind of limitation,
or any kind of commitment to rates
that were pro...
That were posted.
I mean, you just felt
constantly vulnerable
because there were no rules.
In the year...
In September 2000,
this era is probably personified,
or symbolized, by a brutal murder,
an assassination of a
Georgian-Ukrainian journalist...
Young Georgian-Ukrainian
journalist, Georgiy Gongadze,
who had been reporting on corruption,
who was assassinated
during Kuchma's reign.
There wasn't widespread violence en masse
against the population,
but if you were a dissident journalist
or if you were making
trouble in particular,
then you were clearly very vulnerable.
And Ukraine languished this way
until the elections of 2004,
which is really where I
wanna pick up for today.
And the elections of 2004,
the presidential elections,
were the elections between two Viktors.
My kids are always complaining that
all of these people we know
in various Slavic speaking countries,
their names repeat too much.
There are many Agnieszkas
in Poland and Romania.
There are many Viktors,
there are many Sashas.
So this is an election
between two Viktors;
Viktor Yanukovych and Viktor Yushchenko.
And Viktor Yanukovych was your
post-Soviet gangster type.
I mean, not really "type,"
I mean, he was a gangster.
I mean, and not...
My friend, Ivan Krastev,
the Bulgarian political scientist,
said to me once, "Marci,
it's not just that
"he's a gangster,
"he's a petty gangster."
To which Radek Sikorski answered,
"the sums of money involved were
"really not so petty."
Post-Soviet gangster type,
close to the Kremlin,
representing continuity with
what had come before.
The presidency would clearly enrich
himself and his circle of friends.
And then, there was Viktor Yushchenko,
who seemed to be the person
who was Westward-looking,
who was looking towards Europe,
who was going to take Ukraine,
or had visions of taking Ukraine,
on a path towards eventual
European Union integration.
And the short version of
this particular story is
that Yanukovych's team tries
to poison Viktor Yushchenko with dioxin.
Not only tries,
they do poison use Yushchenko with dioxin.
The doctors save him,
but his face is grotesquely disfigured.
And in some ways,
that disfigured face,
the images of Yushchenko
as a victim of this dioxin poisoning,
becomes the face of those elections,
and a symbol of the brutality
and the corruption.
Not only do they poison Yushchenko,
but then they cheat in the elections.
In a way, not so dissimilar
from the way that Lukashenko, in Belarus,
cheated in the elections two years ago.
It was quite obvious to people
that they had forged the election results.
And at that point,
Ukrainians come out onto the streets.
And in particular, they
come out to the main square
in the center of Kyiv.
And the main square in the center
of Kyiv is called the Maidan.
I just wanna say about the Maidan,
it's an unusually large city square,
and it's an unusually
complex geographical space.
So for those of you who are interested
in what is visual,
who are interested in
what is architectural,
it's multi-leveled,
which is not so typical for a city square.
And there's a underground part,
with a subway and with
some underground shopping.
So it's large and complex,
and architecturally offers possibilities
for things to happen on this square.
So for those of you
who haven't been there,
that physical space is significant
to the rest of the story
that I'm going to tell.
And hopefully, you all go some day.
Hopefully, after the victory when
(speaking foreign language).
As they say Ukrainian,
"We can all go back and do
fun things on the Maidan."
Ukrainians go to the Maidan,
to the central square in Kyiv,
and they protest in November 2004.
They protest forged elections.
And Kyiv is very...
It gets very cold in the winter.
It's fairly far north,
not as far north as Petersburg,
but quite far north.
For three weeks, people stand there
and they freeze and they shout.
It's completely nonviolent,
but they insist on free elections.
And somewhat miraculously, it works,
Under pressure to some extent
from other European countries,
but the elections are done over.
This time, Yushchenko
is declared the winner.
And people are happy and they go home.
And as you can probably guess,
this is not going to
be happily ever after.
We're still waiting for
that moment in history
when happily ever after comes,
it's never come,
so we don't want to anticipate too much.
People go home,
and there's a sense of,
"Now, we are on the right path."
But the short version of this story is
that Yushchenko turns out
to be a disappointment.
And hopefully, you'll have some time
to talk in your discussion sections
in more detail about why he turns out
to be a disappointment.
Was he never quite the same
after the dioxin poisoning?
Was he never actually the Messiah figure
that he was projected to be?
Was it because of infighting on his team?
Did it have to do with the falling out
with the Prime Minister Yulia Tymoshenko?
Was he always a little
bit self-interested?
Did he always have certain
nationalist leanings?
For overdetermined reasons that will...
We will never be able to know,
with certainty, exactly what was causal.
It doesn't work out well.
And again, I hope you'll have some time
to talk about this in
your discussion sessions
'cause it was an interesting moment.
And in the meantime, Yanukovych,
it had seemed absolutely impossible
that this man could ever come back.
I mean, first of all,
he was hardly very
inspiring to begin with.
He was...
He had a past that was
a past as a gangster,
he was involved in robbery,
he was involved in assault,
stealing state resources,
being his usual gangster self.
There's nothing particularly
appealing about him.
I realize I'm being very biased here.
And it was publicly exposed
that he poisoned his opponent with dioxin
and cheats in the election,
so you think, really, he's out of there.
But somehow, he's still lurking around
in the background,
and he doesn't give up.
And he finds out that in Washington,
there are some Americans who have
a little boutique industry going
for gangsters with presidential ambitions.
I mean, really, American capitalism,
you can find anything.
And so, he decides he's going to hire
one of these public relations consultants
who specializes in gangsters
with presidential ambitions.
And so, this guy,
whose name was Paul Manafort,
you may have heard of him,
comes over to Ukraine from Washington.
He doesn't know Ukrainian,
he doesn't know Russian,
but he knows how to play golf.
He has opinions about suits,
he has opinions about haircuts,
he has opinions about facial
expressions on television,
and they hang out and he grooms...
Manafort grooms Yanukovych
and gives him a makeover.
Now, again, I realize I'm not
a very objective source
of information here
because I find Yanukovych
somewhat repulsive.
I didn't really see the transformation.
Nothing seemed to be
particularly enchanting about him
after Manafort worked on him.
But somehow, he comes back
and in 2010, genuinely wins the election.
And this time, nobody
disputes the election results.
And as a thank you gift,
he presents Paul Manafort
with a $30,000 jar of black caviar.
I don't even know what one does
with a $30,000 jar of black caviar
but again, I'm speaking as somebody
who doesn't like caviar.
So again, for overdetermined reasons,
I'm not impressed by this.
In any case...
You can tell I'm not really
a neutral observer to this story.
I'm not Ukrainian,
but I'm also not a neutral observer.
It's hard to maintain your stance
as a neutral observer
for a very long time.
In any case, Yanukovych is the president,
he's being his usual gangster-like self,
not particularly inspiring.
He's not offering anyone
some kind of grand narrative.
I mean, he's not one
of these dictators with
"I am going to restore you to greatness."
There's no eschatology,
there's no teleology.
It's just like "the next
gangster could be worse,
"so you better kind of shut up
"and go along with me."
He's not using widespread violence
against the population,
unless you really get in his way,
and then people could be
eliminated here and there.
And he's dangling out the carrot
of eventually, slowly perhaps, one day,
putting Ukraine on a path
towards European Union integration.
And this, for the people,
especially the people
who are exactly your age,
was...
Meant everything.
Whether or not, if you were...
If you were 15, or 18, or 22, or 25,
whether or not Europe was going
to be open to you meant everything
about what kind of future you could have.
Would you be able to
learn foreign languages?
Would you be able to study abroad?
Would you be eligible
for Erasmus exchanges?
Would you be eligible to
do internships in Brussels?
Would you be able to travel,
and go to conferences,
and meet with other young people
without spending months
waiting in long lines,
and humiliating yourself,
and paying lots of money
and pleading for a visa
that you might or might not get?
So this, whether or not the doors
of Europe would be open,
was enormously important,
especially to young people,
and especially to students,
especially to people who
were looking at their future,
who were upwardly mobile,
who wanted to learn languages,
who wanted to see the world.
In November 2013,
Yanukovych was due to sign this
very long anticipated
association agreement
with the European Union.
Now, it was not a fantastic agreement,
and I think that the TFs can tell you
more about the details of this agreement.
It would have involved Ukraine undertaking
costly reforms to get in line
with European Union regulations.
It almost definitely would
have provoked retaliation
from the Kremlin,
who did not want Ukraine associating
more closely with the European Union.
And at the end of the day,
it didn't make any promises
about European Union membership.
This was an association agreement,
it wasn't a membership agreement.
But it was a foot in the door.
It was symbolically of
enormous significance.
It was a sign that Ukraine had intentions
of getting in line with European
standards for integration.
And it was a sign that, potentially,
even if contingently,
if everything went well,
Europe was open to the possibility
of accepting Ukraine.
And so, for an agreement that,
on the face of it and in the details,
didn't seem so spectacular,
it was of enormous symbolic
and existential significance,
especially to a certain demographic.
At the 11th hour, when the ceremony had...
There was a signing ceremony.
It was set up in Vilnius.
Everything was all arranged
for the end of November.
And at the very last minute
on November 21st,
Yanukovych suddenly said,
"No, I'm not gonna sign."
And then there was a feeling of
sudden shock and devastation.
Again, not equally
throughout the population.
And I keep emphasizing that
because it's very different from the war
that's going to come later.
The people who were...
The part of Ukraine that
was truly devastated
by the association agreement was
a more distinct demographic than
the part of Ukraine devastated by the war,
which is a whole country.
At that point, still,
nothing might have happened.
It's one of the lessons
about historical contingency.
People were very depressed,
people were very upset,
people were angry.
Had not a 32 year old
Afghan-Ukrainian journalist,
named Mustafa Nayyem,
not posted on Facebook, in Russian,
a little note on November 21st,
saying, "Hey, let's be serious.
"If you're really upset,
"come out to the Maidan
by midnight tonight."
And he said, "likes do not count."
Interestingly, that "likes do not count"
initially often got
mistranslated to English,
which I found odd because
it's one of the rare,
serendipitous moments
when the Slavic translates
perfectly into English.
It was literally "likes do not count."
And as a historian,
that really captured me
because I thought, "Wow,
"that's a sentence that would have made
"no sense before Facebook."
Like, student...
I mean, literally, it would've been devoid
of any semantic meaning before Facebook.
And now, "Likes do not
count" is going to become
a revolutionary slogan
for the 21st century.
People come out to the Maidan that night.
Mostly, although not exclusively,
young people, students,
people exactly your age,
quite similar to yourselves,
they go out to the square.
It's November, it's cold,
not as cold as it's
going to get in January,
but cold.
They hold hands, they sing,
they play music,
they're completely peaceful.
They're not interested in ethnic politics,
they're not interested
in language politics,
they're not interested in
opposition political parties,
they're not talking about elections.
Their slogan is "Ukraine is Europe."
That's it.
"Ukraine is Europe."
And they call themselves "Euromaidan."
They want Europe to be open to them.
And there are, at any given time,
anywhere from several hundred
to a couple thousand
of them on this square.
They stay there for about nine days.
Again, completely peacefully,
hanging out, dancing,
declaring that "Ukraine is Europe."
And then, at four in the morning
on November 30th,
Yanukovych suddenly,
or not so suddenly,
we don't really know,
I have no privileged
epistemological access
to what was going on inside his head,
perhaps under pressure from Putin,
he decides to send out his riot police,
called Berkut,
to brutally beat up the students.
And this was a shock.
It was a shock because there had been
a tacit social contract that
however much corruption there had been,
however weak the rule of law had been,
however much that people's livelihoods
and resources had been stolen from them,
however a journalist may
have been assassinated
here or there if they were too critical,
since 1991, in independent Ukraine,
the regime had not used mass violence
against its own population.
And there was a sense that
that was a line that was
impermissible to cross.
Nobody was killed,
although that was initially unclear,
but the beatings were really quite brutal
and a lot of people
were seriously injured.
It seems that Yanukovych was counting
on the fact that if you
shock people this way,
not enough to kill people
but enough to terrify them,
the parents will freak out
and they will pull their
kids off the streets.
And one of the people I talked to
about this afterwards was
a great Ukrainian novelist
who writes in the genre
of magical realism,
Taras Prokhasko,
you should all read him, if you haven't,
there's quite a bit that's
been translated into English.
His son, Markian, who was
a young journalism student,
was on the Maidan in Kyiv at the time.
And Taras was in Ivano-Frankivsk,
so he was not there.
He was an overnight train ride away.
But his son, who was a student, was there.
And Markian had been
there for several days.
And just coincidentally,
at like two in the morning
before Berkut came onto the square,
he went to a friend's
apartment and fell asleep.
And he had been on the
square day and night
for the past couple days.
He turned off his phone and went to sleep.
And there's this sudden
outbreak of brutality.
People call...
Phone calls are being made.
Taras gets a phone call,
a message from a girl who knows his son,
and he's trying to get ahold of his son
and he can't.
He's calling, and calling, and calling,
and Markian is not answering the phone.
And he's getting more and more distraught.
I know you guys are too
young to have children,
but it's like...
As soon as you do, you are like...
I already had children by the time
that Maidan came,
and you can feel it under your skin,
this terror about like not being able
to find your children at such a moment.
He's calling hospitals,
he's calling police stations,
he's calling everybody he knows in Kyiv,
and Markian is not answering the phone,
nobody else can find him.
Finally, Markian wakes up,
turns on the phone, finds out...
Finds hundreds of messages,
sees that...
Finds out what's happened.
Calls his girlfriend, now his wife,
she posted a message on Facebook
that says he's alive.
He talks to his mother,
talks to his father,
the things you're supposed to do,
like a good child,
when your parents have been
hysterically worried about you.
Keep that in mind if you're ever
in such a situation.
And Taras immediately gets in his car
and starts driving...
Driving to Kyiv.
And as I said,
it seems that Yanukovych is counting
on the fact that you do something violent,
and shocking, and you terrify parents,
like Taras.
And of course, he was not
the only parent who was terrified.
I'm just telling you his story
because I happened to talk to him.
And he thought they would then pull
their kids off the streets.
They're not gonna expose
their children to this,
And so, Taras is one of the parents
who runs to find their children.
And when he finds Markian,
he doesn't pull him off the street,
he joins him there.
And that's the moment
when everything turns
because that is en masse
what the parents do.
So you go from having had
several hundred to a
couple thousand people
on the streets of Kyiv,
to, a day and a half later,
you have hundreds of thousands of people
on the streets of Kyiv.
Nobody has ever seen that many people
And now, they're not just shouting,
"Ukraine is Europe."
Now, they're shouting,
"We will not permit you
to beat our children."
And interestingly, I heard this also
from people who didn't
have children there per se,
but they all became our children.
"We will not permit you
to beat our children."
And that was the moment that
when I talked to the...
Vasily Cherepanin, who is one of
the leading leftist intellectuals,
who was probably in his
early 30s at the time,
he said "That was the moment
when Euromaidan became Maidan,"
with no prefix.
And it was no longer just about
the European Union.
It was now a revolt against...
Against something that, in Russian,
is called (speaking foreign language).
This is a word we don't have in English,
but during the Trump Administration,
I was suggesting that we needed
to introduce it in English
because it was missing,
which is this idea of
arbitrariness tinged with tyranny.
The sense of helplessness
in the face of power.
The feeling that the powers that be can do
whatever they want to you,
and you are helpless.
That you are being
treated as a play thing,
as a thing and not as a human being,
as an object and not as a subject.
And the maidan became a revolt
against (speaking foreign language).
It became an insistence on being treated
as a person and not as a thing,
as a subject and not as an object,
and they began to call themselves,
"On the Maidan, the
Revolution of Dignity."
And "dignity" here...
I really...
You're gonna...
I'm now exposing myself as
the intellectual historian
who teaches a lot of philosophy.
"Dignity" here in the Kantian sense.
So for those of you who
haven't been subjected
to reading Kant with me,
and if my husband hasn't
told you enough about Kant,
Kant has a famous
definition of a human being.
Kant says that "Whatever can be exchanged
"for something of equivalent
value has a price.
"Whatever is beyond all price
"and bears of no equivalent has dignity.
"Human beings are distinguished
"in that we possess dignity.
"We do not have a price,
we possess dignity."
And from this comes Kant's
categorical imperative,
which is the basis of
his moral philosophy,
which is you always treat a human being
as an ends and never as a means,
always as a subject and not as an object.
In this sense, the Maidan was
a very Kantian revolution.
I realized most of the
political commentators were
not talking about Kant
but I said, I'm intellectual historian,
so I feel compelled to talk about Kant.
It was a Kantian revolution.
We wanna be treated as human beings
and we are going to insist
on being treated with dignity.
It was a remarkable moment for me
as a historian because
so many revolutions have been emplotted
as oedipal rebellions.
You can emplot, in fact,
the whole history of communism
as a series of oedipal rebellions,
where each generation rises up
and turned against the fathers.
So the fact that suddenly
you have parents joining
their children on the streets,
and that is the moment that
creates the revolution,
was just an extraordinary thing to witness
in real time.
And then, when I was working on the book,
I became very interested
in interviewing people
in the same family of multiple generations
who went to the Maidan,
because people then started going
to the Maidan with their children,
with their parents,
sometimes with their parents
and their grandparents.
You would have multiple generations going.
And one of the...
One of the people I interviewed,
together with his father,
was this young kid.
I mean, literally a kid.
He was 16, he wasn't even at university,
he was still in secondary school,
named Roman Ratushnyi,
who was on the Maidan from the beginning.
His shoulder was battered in
on November 30th from Berkut.
But he was determined to go back.
He kept going back.
And I was talking at this cafe in Kyiv,
and it must have been December 2014,
to Roman, to his father, Taras.
And Roman was living with
his mother at the time.
And I said, "Your m..."
I mean, he seemed so young to me,
and I said, "Your mother
must have been very upset,
"but she let you go back."
And he said, "My mother?
"My mother was making Molotov cocktails
"on her (indistinct)."
Yes.
One of the horrific pieces of news
I got in the spring early in this war was
that Roman, before his 25th birthday,
was killed in June,
fighting in the East.
After that, within a couple days,
the Maidan became a whole parallel polis.
Parallel polis was a
concept that was developed
by the Czech dissident
philosopher, Vaclav Benda,
in the late 1970s.
And it was the idea that
to oppose the regime,
to oppose tyranny,
was not just, or should not be primarily,
"we're going to have a political protest."
It was to create an alternative space,
an alternative society,
with your own institutions,
in which you live according to the values
as you wish to see them instituted
in the society as you wish to imagine it.
The Maidan became a parallel polis.
Within 48, 72 hours,
there were elaborate kitchens running,
there was a whole infrastructure.
People were cooking soup in cauldrons,
they were making tea,
they were making coffee,
there was clothing distribution points,
a piano, a stage, a library,
an open university, medical clinics.
There was a whole world going on
in the Maidan.
People were living on the Maidan.
People were coming
every day to the Maidan.
Some of them were coming in shifts
to the Maidan,
walking around the Maidan.
It was getting colder and colder,
so you couldn't stand still,
you had to keep walking.
There were cleanup crews.
One of the other young students
who was on the Maidan,
who now is fighting in the East,
and who I worry about every
day, Misha Martynenko,
said "the Maidan was so clean
"you could eat off the pavement."
Everybody was taking care of this space.
This was their space.
People were suddenly not drinking alcohol,
which was extremely unusual,
like in Kyiv in the winter.
There were performances,
there were lectures,
there were discussion groups,
there was a whole world
that took place there.
It was a masterpiece of self-organization.
And interestingly, there was a sense
of an explosion of civil society,
of self-organization,
in a way that hadn't been anticipated.
But I found when I pushed,
that you could find the origins
in these much smaller instances,
or more modest instances of civil society,
that had been percolating
beneath the surface.
At one point, my friend, Katya Mischenko,
who was shuttling back and forth
at the time between Vienna,
where she had a fellowship, and Kyiv,
who was...
Among other things,
she was guarding patients
at hospitals from being kidnapped
by Yanukovych's people,
which was something he liked to do.
Protestors would be injured by Berkut,
and then while they were vulnerable
in the hospital,
they would be kidnapped and taken away.
And Katya was...
Came back to Vienna one day,
and all of us were jumping on her
and say, "Okay, tell us what's going on.
"Tell us what's going on."
And she was talking about
guarding people at the hospital,
and how they had organized teams,
and there was an SOS hotline
and if you saw somebody taken away,
you could call this number.
And there were these people with cars,
and they were on this program.
And I said, "Katya, how'd you guys get
"an SOS hotline overnight,
"in a couple hours?
"How did you get it so fast?"
And she said, "Oh, well,
there was an LGBT group
"that had a confidential hotline."
It was small, it was under the radar.
You could call and discuss
personal issues, but...
And so, they just turned it over
to the Maidan.
And I found that an interesting detail
because it suggests that
even if something is kind of...
Is in a very nascent, modest stage,
any little bit of infrastructure,
once it's there,
then becomes a jumping off point.
You've already got a hotline set up.
Maybe it's a small hotline,
maybe it doesn't get many calls,
but it's there.
And once these little
pockets of things were there,
it turned out that there was a springboard
that was unanticipated.
It was an extraordinary thing to watch.
There was also this sense of
what Europe meant changed.
I think Europe was no longer,
first and foremost, the highly imperfect,
contingent empirical manifestation
that was the European Union.
Europe was Europe,
in the kind of platonic essence
of Europe-ness.
Europe represented human dignity,
it represented human rights,
it represented the rule of law.
It represented western civilization
in the sense that Gandhi meant
when he was one...
Gandhi was once famously asked
what he thought about
Western civilization,
and he gives this answer,
which some of you may have heard,
"I think it would be a very good thing."
I mean that Europe,
that would be a very good thing,
was the Europe that was
at stake on the Maidan.
The essence of what it would be
to live under a regime of human rights
and the rule of law.
The other thing I wanna talk about
that was so remarkable to me,
and goes back to the idea
of the overcoming of
a generational divide,
is this overcoming of boundaries.
And I should say, my perspective
on this was influenced
by the fact that I was...
I was an American in Vienna,
watching this livestreamed.
And the people in the
Maidan set up cameras
to live stream themselves,
so the Maidan was live
streamed 24 hours a day
on the internet,
which is also an uncanny, trippy thing.
People turned the cameras on themselves.
You were kind...
It was a self-violation
of one's own privacy
in an effort to assert
one's own narrative.
And so, I was an American,
watching this livestream from Vienna,
but in some ways, I was watching it,
above all, through Polish eyes.
I mean, I was following the
press in different languages,
including in English and German.
But the coverage I was
somehow clinging to most was
the coverage coming from Poland.
And in particular, what
my friends in Poland,
who had been veterans of Solidarity
in the 70s and 80s,
and who had sat in prison under communism,
were writing.
And maybe, I'll just take
a little brief detour here
to say something about that.
So there's...
There are two remarkable Polish films,
which you should all watch,
by the great director, Andrzej Wajda.
They're in a series
starring Krystyna Janda,
"Man of Marble" and "Man of Iron."
And in the second one, "Man of Iron,"
it...
Early in the film,
we are in 1968 in Poland.
In 1968 in Poland,
the students lead protest
against communist government censorship,
and many of them end up in prison,
including many of those
people who were still...
Who were watching the Maidan,
and who I was in close
touch with watching this.
And in the film, one...
Which is fictional, but
based on real events.
A young man, a student,
goes to his father, who
is a shipyard worker,
in 1968, as the communist
secret police are coming
and battering the students,
and asks his father to
bring out the workers
in solidarity with the students.
And the father refuses,
and he locks the son in his room,
and he says, "Someday,
when the time is right,
"we'll march together."
And the son is livid.
And he says, "No, I
will never forgive you.
"We will never march together."
And two years later, in Poland,
it's the shipyard workers who demonstrate
against the regime.
And in the film,
in Wajda's film, "Man of Iron,"
the father then comes to his son
and ask him to bring
him and his friends out
in solidarity with the workers.
And at that time,
the son basically says,
"Hey, you let us down two years ago,
"now you go to hell."
And what Solidarity was in Poland,
both in its proto form,
as the Committee for the
Defense of the Workers,
which was spearheaded by Adam Michnik
and others in 1976,
and then the form it evolves into
through 1980 and 1981,
was this remarkable moment
of the coming together
of the fathers and the sons,
and the workers and the intellectuals,
and the Catholics and the Marxist,
and the Jews and the Poles,
and all of these hitherto
existing boundaries.
And that was what happened on the Maidan.
You had people who never
in their lives would have
encountered one another,
who wouldn't have necessarily been
on the same side,
who wouldn't have shared a common way
of understanding the world,
suddenly encounter one another
with this kind of openness
that people would not have expected.
And it was watching...
I think part of my captivation was seeing
how people like Konsta Gebert,
and Adam Michnik, and Aleksander Smolar,
and these veterans of Solidarity
were watching the Maidan
because they knew better than anybody else
that that Solidarity,
that Solidarno
in Poland represented it,
that it lasted 20 seconds
after communism fell.
But they also knew that it was
this extraordinarily precious thing
that most people never experience,
and they never counted on living
to see a second time in their lifetimes.
And they appreciated it,
they knew what it meant.
They knew that it was that miracle
that most people never experience.
And that that was what
the Poles understood
about the Maidan.
I think that's why the
coverage was so different.
In the German press,
people were talking
about the kids in Kyiv,
supportively, but in a
slightly condescending way.
In the Polish press,
they were talking about
powstanie.
powstanie,
which is insurrectionary.
It's like this romantic, lofty,
noble word in Poland,
to talk about powstanie.
"Those who fight for
our freedom and yours."
Okay, I see I'm...
Okay, I see I'm running out of time,
so let me...
People stay on the Maidan.
They stay all winter.
They stay and freeze,
and the stakes get higher and higher,
and the government violence becomes
more and more severe.
Peoples disappear.
Sometimes their bodies are found,
having been tortured and frozen
in the woods.
Activists are frozen and
battered with fire hoses.
There are...
There's a sense that the
violence is only increasing.
And again, it seems to be
that Yanukovych is saying,
"If you keep raising the stakes,
"it's going to stop."
But it has the opposite effect
because at a certain point,
you can push people to
the other side of fear.
You can push them to the point
where they feel that
"no one will ever be safe
"as long as this man is in power.
"The only way any of us are going
"to be able to breathe again is
"if he's overthrown."
The stakes become all or nothing.
Remarkably...
I mean, even watching from a distance,
even watching this livestream,
you could feel a kind of
existential transformation.
When those students went out
to the Maidan in November,
nobody was thinking,
"We're gonna die here,"
or "We're ready to die here."
And by the second half of January,
you could feel, almost palpably,
and even from a distance
that something had turned,
and a critical mass of people was ready
to die there if need be.
And then, you were kind of...
You were just waiting for the end game.
You knew that more
violence was going to come,
and you knew that those
people were not gonna leave.
And there was this sense
of voyeuristic terror
that I was watching this with,
and many people were watching this with.
This happened in the second
half of February 2014,
where Yanukovych's regime unleashes
a sniper massacre,
and there are snipers on
buildings firing down.
And this is all being live streamed,
so you are watching people being killed
in real time.
You're watching these
battles in real time.
More and more reinforcements
start coming to Kyiv.
In Lviv, there's a former
real estate agent...
Or she's still a real estate agent now,
but she turned herself into
a committee to organize buses.
They were just putting people on buses
and sending people to Kyiv.
And people wanted to go.
More people wanted to go
than they could produce buses.
Radek Sikorski, who was
the Polish Prime Minister
at the time during this massacre,
flies over to Kyiv
to try to negotiate a ceasefire.
He goes to the presidential palace
to talk to Yanukovych.
The presidential palace is very close
to the Maidan.
I mean, Radek gets there
and you can smell the smoke.
I mean, things are burning,
buildings are burning,
people are burning.
You can smell the smoke
in the presidential palace.
He goes in to talk to Yanukovych.
I found this...
I found this kind of extraordinary
because I thought...
When I talked to him afterwards,
I thought, "Radek, you're sitting there,
"talking to this man.
"You know that with every
"additional five minutes that takes,
"more people are being killed.
"And you know you're talking to someone
"for whom other people's lives
"just don't have any value.
"I mean, was he at all concerned about
"these people who were being killed
"as you were talking to him?"
And Radek is like,
"Marci, he doesn't have much
of an emotional imagination.
"He's not that bright.
"No, he didn't seem concerned at all."
But finally, they managed
to negotiate a ceasefire,
and a call for early elections.
Yanukovych agrees to early elections.
Not immediately, but
several months from then.
People in the Maidan do not wanna sign it.
They don't trust the president.
They've just seen their people die.
Radek takes a very hard line stance
and says, "Hey, listen,
"I grew up in Poland under Solidarity.
"We underestimated the
strength of the regime,
"and we got martial
law and mass detention.
"So you accept this now.
"Later, you push for more.
"Otherwise, you're gonna get the army,
"you're gonna get martial law,
"you're all gonna be dead."
And they sign.
But it's clear that
people are just furious.
I mean, they're carrying
corpses in caskets
through the Maidan,
and Yanukovych flees.
He flees across the border to Russia.
And Paul Manafort is out of a job.
We all know what he does next.
Little green men
in unmarked camouflage appear
on the Crimean Peninsula,
sent by the Kremlin.
While no one has had a
chance to catch their breath,
one president has fled,
he's been deposed.
There's an interim government,
but they haven't had elections yet
and nobody really knows what's going on.
And Putin capitalizes on, particularly,
that moment to try to take Crimea...
To take Crimea,
and to instigate separatist rebellions
throughout eastern and
southeastern Ukraine.
So-called "Russian tourist"
come across the border.
They have been told various stories,
one of which is that the Maidan was
a CIA-sponsored conspiracy,
and that Ukrainian Nazis
are now heading east
to kill all the Russian speakers.
I don't have time to go into,
unfortunately, the rest of that story,
but I'm sure after the break,
you will be caught up as to what happens
after the annexation of Crimea
and the beginning of
the war in the Donbas.
Let me just...
Maybe if I can say something philosophical
and existential at the end.
So I'm not really a
political historian per se.
One of the things that struck me most
about the accounts people were giving
on the Maidan was how
everybody started talking about
how they lost track of time.
Something happens to time
during a revolution.
It changes its form.
You can't remember what
happened an hour ago,
what happened the day before,
what happened a week before.
I mean, one of the principles
of revolution is that the state of affairs
that obtained five
minutes ago could become
completely irrelevant five minutes later.
That anything can change at any moment.
That suddenly, there was an effacing
of the boundary between night and day.
You could call anyone at any time.
(That)
That was true if you were
15 or if you were 75,
that the experience of time changed.
And I became very interested
in thinking about time.
Time and revolution.
And one of the things I learned
from the Maidan,
or learned from the accounts of the Maidan
that I was getting from my friends,
and colleagues, and other people
who were there,
was an appreciation of
Sartre's idea of time,
of the present.
The present is a border.
The present is a border between...
Between what Sartre
calls "the inward self."
Facticity, what has already happened,
who you have been up to this moment,
what cannot be changed,
and "the forward self."
What is coming in the future,
what is not yet determined,
what is the possibility for transcendence,
to go beyond what has been
and who you have been up to this moment.
And that border is with us,
every moment of our lives.
The present is the moment
of that crossing of the border
from what has already been
and who we have been
to the possibility of going beyond,
but we normally don't feel it,
we normally don't turn
our attention to it.
And revolution is that moment
when you suddenly shine a glaring light
on that border,
and you are shaken into
understanding the present
as the moment of the
possibility of going beyond.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(calm music)